and welcome this friday night to hannity
tonight the deep state the democratic
party at the media mob they are once
again teaming up to promote yet a brand
new conspiracy theory this time the
hysteria might be worse than ever you
have two msdnc fan favorites they are
now suggesting that donald trump should
be executed can't make it up also
tonight remember john paul mack isaac
the computer repairman
he's going to join us now he turned over
hunter biden's laptop to the fbi
and according to him he now is telling
us that he was threatened by agents to
stay quiet his story is straight ahead
also hunter meanwhile take a look
pictured here beautiful kiawah beach
south carolina enjoying a lavish
vacation with his father footloose fancy
free we'll have more on the double
standard in this country as it relates
to justice but first we begin with a
text
from august the 8th 2016. why do we stop
here
stay with us at the time top fbi uh
lawyer lisa page absolutely distraught
she was terrified at the prospect that
donald trump would be elected president
she
texted her colleague and lover top fbi
investigator peter strzok quoting quote
trump's not ever going to become
president right strzok responded no he's
not we'll stop it then a week later
strzok texted quote i believe that the
path that you threw out for
consideration in andy's office we assume
andy mccabe that there is no way he gets
elected but i'm afraid we can't take
that risk it's like an insurance policy
in the unlikely event you die before
you're 40. so they had an insurance
policy and they wanted to stop donald
trump from ever becoming president and
they had a plan to do so in the weeks
and months that followed well there were
two main attempts by the fbi and the doj
to destroy donald trump the first was a
totally debunked russia alpha bank
trump's tower service story that went
nowhere and then the second one was more
sinister that was hillary clinton and
her dirty russian misinformation dossier
that she paid for and despite warnings
from bruce ohr in august of 2016 even
john brennan warning obama that the
dossier was political op research and
not to be trusted despite claims from
the dossier author christopher steele
that the material was unverifiable well
regardless of all of that the fbi used
the dossier to obtain fisa warrants not
once but four times to go after one
innocent american carter page and also
as a backdoor into the trump campaign
later the trump transition team team and
yes the trump white house they also used
it as a basis for the multi-year mueller
witch hunt so you might be asking
yourself why would august of 2016 be
relevant
well notwithstanding the hard-working
fbi agents at field offices around the
country the 95-6 6 of good people that
protect us from the cartels and drug
dealers and human traffickers and and
the mob and everyone else since 2016 we
have chronicled on this show the upper
echelon the seventh floor of the fbi
that has made it their priority to take
down donald trump to stop him at all
costs and i've been one of the biggest
supporters of law enforcement my entire
career over 35 years in radio 26 years
here on the fox news channel but we
chronicled over three years this abuse
of power this corruption it has now
created sadly a well-deserved distrust
in the fbi and the doj and these
institutions not the rank and file but
those with the most power that are
corrupt that did abuse their power and
that have now done it for nearly seven
years they have waged a political war
using all the tools and all the power at
their disposal to go after one man
donald trump and last night in a story
published by the washington post here we
go again sound familiar because we went
through seven years of this anonymous
sources claiming this week's raid and
mar-a-lago has something to do with
nuclear weapons so of course uh-oh it's
been a bad week for the doj and a bad
week for the fbi uh because uh now they
got a tip so they can scare every
american no no donald trump was going to
do something with nuclear weapons
from an anonymous uh no-name person
feeding the washington post like they
have for all these years obviously a
trump hater the same media mob that
printed every lie every distortion every
conspiracy theory that was also a part
of the hoax the same the same tactics
they have used against donald trump
since the day he came down that
escalator you know we're just supposed
to believe that nearly two years after
trump left the white house all of a
sudden the feds had to go in unannounced
by force and search the president's home
uh when they were there in june they
were welcomed with open arms a matter of
imminent national security they claim 19
months later and according to newly
released court documents the raid had
something to do with a violation of what
the very broad rarely used espionage act
of 1917 and more specifically the warren
sites 18 u.s 793 gathering transmitting
or losing defense information along with
18 usc 2071 which is concealment removal
or mutilation of records records 18 ufc
1519 the destruction alteration or
falsification of records and federal
investigations we'll have more on this
with professor dershowitz in a moment
and according to the property receipt
federal agents took what approximately
20 boxes of papers photos hand-written
notes about roger stone material about
the the president of france other
documents no mention of nuclear weapons
but if it's not there i'm sure they'll
magically find it in one of their own
desks now keep in mind the former
president did not oppose the release of
the property receipt or the fbi's
warrant on truth social just the
opposite he said release the documents
now he continued quote not only will i
not oppose the release of documents
related to the un-american unwarranted
unnecessary raid and break-in of my home
in palm beach florida mar-a-lago i'm
going a step further by encouraging the
immediate release of these documents now
donald trump has nothing to hide because
he did nothing wrong these materials
were seized by the feds where they were
from trump's time in the white house
they were packed up by government
staffers they were delivered to trump's
post-presidential office no different
than any other president before him
obama bush clinton all took documents
clinton also took furniture and other
things and by the way all presidents and
this is very important tonight they all
have the power to declassify anything
they want to declassify now still
president trump's office has been
cooperating with the national archives
for many many months and according to a
statement
from them in the archives in february
quote throughout the course of the last
year
that the national archives and record
administration obtained the cooperation
of trump representatives to locate
presidential records that had not been
transferred to the national archives at
the end of the trump administration they
said in writing that they were
cooperating quote trump's
representatives handed over several
boxes in february and they invited
federal officials to mar-a-lago to
review the remaining materials as a
matter of fact the doj and the fbi were
at mar-a-lago in june of this year they
were free to take anything that they
wanted to take they didn't they didn't
need a warrant they were invited to come
back for whatever they might need at any
time and trump at their request even put
up a padlock in the room that was
storing the documents they requested
that so why raid the former president's
home why now hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else